Rowland since I'm kind of a cutting-edge
technology guy I get asked a lot of
technical questions so I'm gonna answer
a few of them now for Wired magazine
dear Jerry edge' okay I think my
neighbor is feeding my cat is it cool to
use a drone to spy on him what's what's
wrong with someone feeding your cat
seems like they're doing you a favor
leave him alone here's one from Billy in
San Francisco who says I like coffee and
I like cars can I be on your show
no from Amy Cleveland misspelled Ohio
dear mr. wonderful if someone posts
about a death in their family is it
appropriate to like the post yes yes
death is not a hundred percent bad we
need the room from my would you get that
thank you
for Marcus Bourbon all right
just get it stop that sound from Marcus
Bourbon California is it okay to video a
concert with my iPad sure sure go ahead
so you won't enjoy the concert and you
won't enjoy the video so you'll have
negated everything is it hazardous to
tweet on ambien I don't think so I don't
think there's anything that can go wrong
with a tweet so the tweet I think it's
interesting that we developed tweeting
because we so admired birds that we saw
them in trees just sitting on branches
going we thought oh my god well we got
to be doing this
we also must drop an annoying series of
small daily turds upon the earth the
first tweet by the way was and it meant
sex worms
hashtag rocks my world our human
resource director just posted a nude
photo of herself on Facebook is it okay
to like it I've never had a job
not interested dear Joey Joey Joey that
must be for the Joey Fatone shoot that
we're doing after this one have you
cashed in your bitcoins yet very clever
using a trendy word dear Jerri if my
friend doesn't respond to my text is it
okay to obsessively keep sending more
texts until he replies also what is a
restraining order
who wrote this you can't spell at all
then restaining
missed everything even spells in dear
Jerri I work in Silicon Valley we
already don't like you not interested
get a life no don't care my tweets are
friggin hilarious no they're not because
the word frigging is lame hang on hello
ya wired I know